possible esse yes there is are you doing
yes dad I told you Patrick we come on
live I told you Pat man you're my father
is such a huge fan I mean I'm a huge fan
you got my first Shore and you know me
like I have leaders creators on YouTube
but oh you're the dopest coolest you're
the dopest coolest entrepreneur so
you're out here with YouTube and your
show is the coolest I just sit up my dad
we watch some of those mobster
interviews and me and my dad get such a
awesome quality time together bro alumna
I'd love to hear that yeah yeah it's so
cool so how you been how you how you
doing yourself how you feeling you know
what man I feel great bro cuz I feel my
I've worked so hard throughout my entire
life to understand what a leader really
truly is my father raised me with these
principles since I was young I've been
through you know I've been through the
last crisis and I just feel like you
know this is such a beautiful
opportunity for me to step up and show
up even more as a leader for my team for
my community so it's just for my
business and it's just it's beautiful
man I feel like I'm I'm not pushing
people to really step up to be the
leaders that they're called to be and I
feel like you know as a millennial
Patrick I feel our generation is so
important that we have leaders because
we grew up with social media we grew up
with this culture of followers a culture
of trying to be light and this culture
of you know comparing ourselves and it's
it's manipulated us and I feel like it's
happened since we were kids with the
media and education system and bro like
right now more than ever before this
generation this time in history this
decade this era is probably the most
important decade in humanity looking at
what's happening right now around the
world so the fact that I get an
opportunity right now to play a role in
this to help people especially in my
generation to know what it's like to
lead their life is really important to
me and I feel blessed to be in this
position
I love it I love it I go ahead thank you
thank you well bro thank you so much for
taking time to be here man I look up to
you I admire you so much a CEO what's up
Alec I see you we have a really amazing
group here you know I guess I have a
couple personal things I want to ask you
you know and I got some things I just
want to ask you also in regards to
what's happening I guess I'll start with
you being one of the most successful
powerful CEOs and entrepreneurs of our
time you know how do you think right now
an entrepreneur CEO can thrive coming
out of this current state of economy can
thrive coming out of this current state
of the car right now
yeah so I I will tell you you know
sometimes when when we're places and
we're going through things like you know
when you're an 18 year old kid you go to
a nightclub for the first time or you
went when you were 16 years old to a
nightclub and you around your peers and
you're trying to kind of a go and talk
to the girl or all that other stuff and
you kind of you're all your friends are
trying to do everything in and then
you're noticing yourself you kind of get
shy when something happens or you your
spirit kind of gets come confident in a
certain area maybe you're you know you
know you can dance well and all over
someone who comes out to dancing you
kind of have your chin up a little bit
and you kinda like well you know what I
think I can hang with my peers in this
area of a partying or you go play
basketball at a YMCA or at a certain
league or in the streets of Venice
whatever it is and then you go in at
first you kind of hesitant and then all
of a sudden the game starts you're like
you know what I just made a couple shots
I block the ball I stole the buy give
this guy an assist I can play with these
guys and then you all of a sudden are
kind of like you know maybe I'm under
estimating my abilities or you go to the
military and you go to boot camp and
you're noticing you're like I'm not
gonna know how I'm gonna respond to
these kinds of times but on the outside
everybody looks kind of tough and we're
kind of like yeah this is nothing you
know I can handle it I remember one time
I take a crazy story here I go to boot
camp and it's four of us leaving from LA
it's myself
it's this guy from ms-13 it's another
guy that's informer 18th Street guy and
it's another guy that's a soccer player
short guy 5 7 5 8 guys we go to boot
camp
so we fly out from LA to Atlanta we land
at Atlanta they put us in a Greyhound
and from grey hat with a greyhound we go
to South Carolina to go to our base for
Jackson South Carolina we go to the base
the drill sergeants come out screaming
they're grabbing or you know they're
throwing it out or closer all over the
place and they're hollering our ears
they're hitting our head with their hat
that they have the drill sergeant hat
and then you go in the drive to the base
everybody's talking hard everybody
everybody's like man I grew up in the
streets of LA this is nothing to me do
you realize what I am I represent this
I've seen bullets I've seen gun shots
I've seen all this stuff damn boot camp
starts there first B goes by then 2nd
week goes by then there's a quiet kid on
the corner no one's even paying any
attention to white guy skinny maybe 130
pounds on a good day one but he looks
like a weak guy he looks like a timid
guy the next thing you know fast forward
the tough guy with all the tattoos he
can handle it and he choked and he rang
the bell and he says I got to go home I
can't take this I got to go back to my
family five weeks later he thrown the
towel and went home the guy that
everybody thought was the toughest kind
of unit quit the guy everybody
underestimated today is the senator of
Ohio
Frank Villa Rose we keep in contact
together he's a senator and we weren't
the same base together this guy was I
got the chills all over my body this guy
was a quiet guy it were your apart we're
on the same floor and would always seem
like somebody that wasn't gonna be
somebody but when it came down to the
spirit got bigger and bigger and bigger
what is this all stuff me we talked
about going to a nightclub we talked
about playing basketball we talked about
being on a military sea
you really don't know who you are until
times like this show up today for CEOs
to really separate themselves this is
hell week except it's hell quarter in
just the hell week hell week a
summertime 85 degrees 90 they
in the Sun your training morning till
now your body's sore you can't run
anymore how many more suicides do I need
to do coaches screaming at you your
peers are hitting you the tires whatever
it is you're doing this is hell quarter
you're about to find out how much you
can take control of your imagination
you're about to find out how much you're
gonna let your imagination sabotage you
gonna be able to control all the news
and media telling you that the end of
the world is here and whoever is able to
play the mind game and the emotional
game today is gonna be seen as a leader
amongst their peers is going to be seen
as a leader amongst their teammates is
gonna be seen as a leader monster family
and three six twelve months from now
whenever somebody looks for crisis
leader whenever somebody looks for war
town order they're gonna say you know
what that person's got it so when you
ask that question I think this is more
of a hell quarter for everybody as a
leader to consider if you can really
hack it during these times or not
because if you can
when this thing goes by I tell you we
are gonna see some of the biggest rock
stars that we've never seen before
because they could handle like during
times like this if he can handle times
like this when your company is about to
go out of business everybody chokes
you're gonna go through it when your
enemies are coming after you're not
going to go through when people are
talking behind your back with defamation
of character start gonna bother you so
these are some of the best training
grounds we could be going through right
now I love it
so Patrick where were you during the
last economic recession where were you
who were you as an entrepreneur back
then were you what kind of business and
where were you at in a mindset
perspective versus now that's such a
great question so I got out of the
military June of 99 and then a day
before 9/11 I start working on Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter so I go and become a
stockbroker but a day before 9/11 so
it's nine ten its Monday the next
state's 9/11 and in Gerard I'm supposed
to go to New York to the World Trade
Center cuz Morgan Stanley's headquarters
is that the World Trade Center so last
minute they changed their training they
sent us to Mark Hopkins Hotel in San
Francisco they did training there in San
Fran instead of New York when 9/11
happened my broker Dave Kirby satisfied
in the morning and he says let me tell
you guys this much the next three years
in this industry it's gonna be very
difficult
says no one's gonna want to buy from you
no one's gonna want to buy stocks right
now people don't want to talk to you
everybody's afraid it's a war that's a
true Black Swan because that was a
surprise nobody was expecting something
like that to happen that's never
happened to America before the pandemic
is more like a White Swan because we've
been through SARS or you know some of
these things in the past she every body
was shocked
and I had no idea what to do I looked
around I'm like oh my gosh I don't know
what to do man everybody one by one by
one everybody was quitting and everybody
was leaving to get a regular safe bank
job they're like I'm not gonna be a
broker working for Commission's I'm out
of here
and then I snuck in and I watched
everybody and I watched everybody and I
watched everybody next thing you know I
went to a left Morgan I went to
Transamerica during that period I lost
everything I'm forty nine thousand
dollars in debt Morgan Stanley has not
given up my license because they spend a
year training he said they wouldn't give
up my securities license my series seven
and sixty-six to leave yeah I was
selling t-shirts you can actually see
the video on YouTube I was selling
t-shirts on the corner of Reseda and
Nordoff right next to Cal State
Northridge I would take my shirt off
because I had a decent physique and I
would stand in the corner I'm not even
kidding with I would stand in the corner
I had two shirts I was selling one of
them was united we stand which I sold
for ten bucks and the other one I had
was Osama yo mama
I was selling for twenty and if you
bought both of them isola two for
fifteen bucks so I did that I will buy
these t-shirts for $2 and I would sell
it for fifteen bucks that I kind of
helped me survive and in the next time
in 2008 you know when a mortgage crisis
took place it was my biggest year of my
career because at this point of the game
I was prepared due to 2001 yeah Wow so
man I just commented like the cometh is
real who here like comment below you
know if if you know that feeling right
like that feeling of like being at that
rock bottom moment but doing whatever it
took being willing to do whatever it
took you know and I've been there those
moments in my life as well because like
back throwing the last recession was
when I lost everything but interesting
because you mentioned stocks I was a
marketer for publicly traded companies I
would help them to tell their stories I
would go and look for
or small cat publicly traded companies
that were these innovators and I would
help them back then before we had social
media I was helping them get written in
blogs I would help them an email
marketing pay-per-click ads anything I
could do to help their story get heard
by investors we call that investor
awareness it also was known as like
stock promoters in a sense right and
when the economy crashed I was like
before it did I was like this kid who
had it all I was buying sneakers I was
making I went from getting my first pie
for five hundred dollars I would stay up
til 4:00 in the morning just like I was
obsessed with like reaching out to
companies faxing I used to fax back then
CEOs to say give me a shot to tell your
story got my first client or five
hundred dollars grew that to ten million
dollar agency by the time I was 24 the
economy crashes and I now know companies
want to hire for investor like the no
one wanted to spend any money any
publicly traded company I had put all my
money in the stock market lost it all
and I was stuck with nothing and I
remember talking about I remember
talking to my mother who helped me to
learn to bounce out of that and say
listen you can lose all the money in the
world but they never take this and they
can never take this go out there and do
it again and that's what got me to be
inspired Oh making documentaries around
the economy and you know and and there
was the birth of elite daily.com
which then became the number one
millennial publication in the United
States so it's like right now each one
of you right now has this opportunity to
step up right now in lead and create
that vision and start not looking at all
these outside of circumstances and blame
but really step into what can you create
right now how can you step up and create
something that's needed and solve a
problem in the world right now so that
you can become a CEO and a leader like
Patrick right so Patrick what are some
of your favorite or some of the business
principles that you live by
currently right now to me it's alignment
alignments at the highest level so you
know one day I sat down I'm on a flight
and I have a five and a half hour flight
I took a piece of paper out and I
started writing questions for myself and
I said so write down the most
the time of your life and I started
writing them down so write down the
people that have believed in you the
most I wrote them down write down the
people that have been your biggest
critics and haters in your life that
have hurt you the most I wrote it down
write down the defining moments of your
life so I wrote it down I'm like okay so
I'm looking at this point it again
person sitting next and I'm covering
myself because I'm I got emotional and
I'm like I don't want this person to
look at me because you know you got some
pride you don't want to show somebody on
the flight what the hell is this guy
crying for yeah
Careless Whisper under you know under oh
phone you know are you thinking about it
girl I'm like no I'm actually my life
but I took a sheet of paper and I wrote
out the values and principles I want to
build my life on and that became the
journey of what values and principles I
wanted to build my life on as a friend
as a business partner as a businessman
as a leader as a parent as in every
possible way then any time in my life
Gerard I have swayed away from values
and principles that matter to me the
most I've been very miserable yeah
anytime my values and principles match
my behavior and how I live I've been
very effective yeah I think the biggest
thing is one not compromising your
rallies and principles regardless of
doing business with people regardless if
you bring in a investor in a regardless
if you're hiring a new executive
regardless if you're going into business
with somebody don't compromise your
values and principles and then outside
of that I have some basic principles
which is who's doing a webinar early
this morning and one of the guy asked me
says what does your confidence come from
if you compete what do you compete in I
said to me I don't compete on how big
you are today versus me meaning if I'm
coming up I don't look at another person
I said oh my gosh look how much farther
they are from us I only compete at who's
grown at a faster percentage today
that's my competition and I don't
compete in a league you're running a
billion-dollar company I'm running a 50
million dollar company I can sit there
and think about it all day long I'm
gonna be depressed because you're 20
times bigger than me yeah but if I look
at this and I see I'm grown at a 75%
rate and you're going at a 3% rate the
last nine years
listen eventually we're gonna catch up
to you so it's about the principles of
improving so outwork out and prove out
strategize outlast which is the last one
we don't figure out cause you
never know who's got the most stamina in
the game because most people cannot
handle the mental and emotional torture
the stamina you got up courage wisdom
tolerance understanding and the two
things I teach my kids every night is
never bully anybody and also don't get
bullied that's pretty much some of the
principles I love I love that bro I love
that I love that guys listen you know
this is uh this is sound true like true
if someone who's a trusted adviser some
of you can really trust and like you
know this is sound advice guys like
getting clear on your values getting
clear on your principles that you live
by and sometimes it hurts but what a
great time than right now and I really
feel like I don't know about you Patrick
like if there had been these values that
were instilled in you at a young age
from your family and off important
family is to you I want to talk about
that I have some real core principles
that my father gave me at a very young
age but I definitely have over time I've
changed
I mean I've evolved and you know I've
just recently reevaluate and my team and
like really start to think about like
how am i defining those values and how
am I making sure that not only am i
living by those values myself but that
my team in the business that I'm
creating they clearly know these values
and they know what I mean by these
values because I may say my value is you
know transparency but that may mean
something different to me than it may
mean to them and sometimes you got to be
really clear to define these values and
then make sure that everybody on your
team inherits those values and that
those values are being you know really
lived by by your team and by the your
customers and community like so for me
I've just really dated it just recently
what those are how those evolved for you
over time oh yeah no doubt about it
absolutely you know when I was uh when I
was single and I made a decision I'm not
gonna get married
I enjoy my own company I enjoy going to
movies by myself and I sit down I can
have my own fun I can go and the travel
and I'll have a blast because I know how
to entertain myself very well but I was
convinced I'm not gonna get married why
my parents their marriage didn't work
out I'm just kind of like look to have
the kids to have the responsibilities to
have this all this other stuff I'm good
I have girlfriends I'm having my fun I'm
go play ball and get married and then
one day I'm sitting on I'm talking my
dad and I'm realizing I'm the only bit
David out there so in order for this bid
David generation to continue there's not
a lot of Assyrians out there maybe it's
a good idea for me to come out go out
there and figure this thing out so I get
a hold of a book called 101 questions to
ask before you get engaged and I think I
told you about this one time when we
spoke about it when you were out here in
Dallas yeah I don't hold it this book
101 questions to ask before you get
engaged and at that time I was talking
to four girls at the time I gave the
book to everybody and once I went
through the questions there was about 50
questions that matter to me I gave the
book to everybody we sat down and we
went through the questions and I said I
can never be with her I can never be
with you I can never be with her we can
date but I can never marry you never in
a million years because I went through
those questions right I also wished
couldn't be married to me
here's what I mean by who can be married
to me I knew that certain cultures were
not gonna do well with me because I'm
not the 95 guy I'm not the 8 to 5 guy
I'm not gonna be ahead of home every
night last night I was at the office at
7 o'clock in the morning last night I
got home at 1:30 last night I'm not on
my house I'm at the office right now
yeah yeah you were working so that now
like we sent 80 of our employees home
and we got 20 of them working right now
because we got a lot of projects that we
were working on right now so I knew who
could say I could be with you
no you can't yes I can I promise you
can't don't tell me I would make it work
no way when the best advice I ever got
about a relationship was men women marry
men hoping they can change them and they
don't meaning women marry men hoping
they'll change and they don't men marry
women hoping they stay the same and they
change and this was given to me by past
a very random advice to give to me right
is that good advice guys hey let me tell
you so this guy gives me the advice and
I was actually talking to another girl
at that time and he says look whatever
it is today if you don't like it and you
can't tolerate it it's gonna get worse
so if you can't handle it today make the
decision and don't be the selfish person
to try to make it and you're gonna have
proms later on so then you get married
you run a business then you start
realizing what works what doesn't work
you watch everyone's behavior and your
values principles and philosophies start
evolving in many different ways you
start realizing that in business you
know you you matter if you want the
spotlight you matter but as much as you
matter you don't matter you realize that
yes you may be the CEO and you got this
fancy title and everything else but the
reality behind closed door CEO really
means everything's your fault it's not
as fancy as you think it is behind
closed doors if you think everything is
everybody else's fault and you're not
taking responsibility for it then next
thing you know nobody wants to work for
you nobody wants to be around you you
know you can't keep type-a personalities
now you can't keep tenzin your company I
was reading a book by this private
equity guy who's one of the biggest
private equity guys in America and he
said for the longest time I was building
my company on recruiting AIDS and he
says you can build a good company have a
lot of AIDS he says Nine's
can do great things in your company he
says but if you start recruiting and
retaining tents now you become the best
of the best I used to be good at getting
seventh and eighth and then I made a
decision to go to the nines at a ten so
in order to keep the nines and the tens
you must change to attract them and even
change even more to keep them so Frost
has to go through so it is a lot of work
but it's a blast going through it guys
comment your number one top core value
you know Patrick
so you've interviewed I mean I I'm
telling you bro you're my friend I mean
this my favorite youtube channel I love
your interviews yo I'm telling you I'm
gonna be the same bro no I'm gonna just
stop wearing my suit I get oh they're
like do my interviews mother you got
such a cool vibe man and I just wanna
know who is something like who your top
three and I'm sure you love everyone
you've interviewed but who are like the
top three interviews that have really
touched you man that I really like
impacted you and that you enjoyed Kobe
Bryant has to be at the top there's no
question about it Kobe Bryant was at the
top and and and not only just because of
the interview but be
of how we connected for the hour prior
to doing the interview and what happened
afterwards if our conversation if we
don't spend an hour and a half in a
boardroom together that interview is not
the same no way in the world when Kobe
and I spend our time together obviously
at this point of the game everybody
remembers a day we heard the news when
Kobe Bryant passed away let me put it
Kobe a comment a heart for Kobe I mean
you know I'll tell you a part about Kobe
that I got the chills all over my body
we're at seasons 52 when Kobe dies okay
and I get text messages I'm like there's
no way in the world I said this is an
ugly prank it's another one of these
Paul Walker pranks people are playing I
don't like this stuff and then CNN
reporters right and in Fox reports and
I'm like what so I'm looking at this my
six-year-old son is sitting next to me
and he knows how to read at this point
he says daddy did that say Kobe Bryant
died I said yes look what he says
Gerard look what he says my son says
daddy
Kobe my friend died think it's cool you
know why he said Kobe my friend died
because when Kobe was there an hour
before he spent 15 minutes talking to my
two sons of my nephew and he spent
another 20 minutes talking to my wife
Wow
the way that guy was off-camera is a
whole different story so impressed by
him purely by off camera so Kobe's on
Dallas President Bush's on that list
even though that interview is at the
Library of Congress we could never go
live with it because I want that
interview to be like we have it but we
can't publish it or else you're gonna
have the White House coming after me or
you know the government coming after me
I can't do that one Sammy the bull
Gravano has to be one yeah well we got
some other things if the pandemic wasn't
going on we had some real crazy stuff
coming out with Sammy we will work
you're not a pretty big project we were
working I'm gonna come out soon once
everything goes back to normal you learn
so much from the mobster the thing that
I love really was like I loved how much
they you learned the art of persuasion
like like from a sales standpoint like
the way that you making someone else and
think that they win you know like his
his whole mindset of how he got Gotti
John God you know
really you know very interesting guy
first time so first time he and I spoke
yeah I just got out of prison we got on
the phone together and I said hey you
know I'd want to be able to talk to you
about doing an interview since the
interview I don't talk to the camera the
last time I did an interview was with
Diane Sawyer what makes you think I want
to do anything he went off for an hour
and a half with me on the phone long
story short we met together first time
in Phoenix and we went in to this one
place we went to the back two and a half
our conversation led to another
conversation and two years a year and a
half later we finally did the interview
I'd say the other interview that was
also very interesting what's Carlos
Mencia because it was a different kind
of an approach we took on trying to get
Carlos and Joe Rogan's to be on the same
room together if you haven't seen that
one that one was a very challenging see
that one yeah yeah it's a very Chand
array value so I would say those would
be my favorite interviews who's one
person you want to interview this year
ah you win I mean the people I want to
interview I wouldn't mind interviewing
Putin
I wouldn't mind interview in the the CEO
of Huawei I wouldn't mind going there
and every interviewing them to kind of
see whether I would mind interview
Maduro I wouldn't mind interview some of
these guys because that's what I want to
ask them but and then obviously you got
a lot of these folks on a business side
that you know any of these luminaries
after I'd love to interview yeah so how
do you prepare for your interviews I
always think the reason why I love your
show is because you just show up it's
it's it's caused me to to really say
move the bar up of my standard of how I
prepare for any of yous but how do you
what's your process for preparing for an
interview so you know the whole format
that did six years ago when I was
thinking about creating content seven
years ago when I was thinking about
creating content I went around to see if
I really want to do this okay if I
really want to do this because it's it's
work don't get me wrong I want to
companies man I run yeah you know the
insurance company with 14,000 agents 130
offices investors attorneys lawyers
carriers and I run by attainment which
is scheduled content interviews a lot of
work and I got three kids wife such a
lot of stuff you got to do but seven
years ago so let me see if I want to do
this and then I went and I saw formats
this is how you do podcasts here's my 15
questions to use all you need to do is
just take - and ask the same question I
think you can do four interviews in a
single day and I said that's not how I
would do it I can't do with that format
because that's vanilla I don't like
vanilla I like you know strawberry
sorbet that's slightly different than
what other people want to do you know I
like certain flavors of banana split
anyways long story short and someone do
it in a different way so if I do an
interview behind closed doors or there's
probably several hours of research
taking place before I sit down with the
person I'm interviewing so it's not the
standard questions and I'll typically if
you see my interviews
I'll typically have 5 to 10 pages of
notes on the desk that I go through one
by one by one and I try to hit up all
the topics so but it's a lot of research
that happens behind closed doors yeah I
noticed that I noticed that it's
phenomenal thank you for doing this work
I know how hard it is especially when
you are a real CEO what do you what do
you feel is the power of being a thought
leader like do you think that you know
if you are a CEO of a company I deal
with a lot of CEOs that like fear doing
this thing because they look at personal
branding and they look at you know being
an influencer and they're just like hey
you know what like you know I don't
think they necessarily see how how we
could actually grow their business or
how can it grow their fulfillment an
impact what would you say to a CEO right
now that you know does want to leave a
legacy does have a message that he wants
to share wants to build a movement but
like doesn't see how to do it where it
will bring value to what you know he or
she is creating I'll ask you the
simplest question simplest question how
much money would you give to have
hundreds of hours of content of your
grandfather how much would you give let
me ask that question one more time how
much money Gerard would you give to have
hundreds of hours of your
great-grandfather telling you about the
lineage of your family what what would
you pay for that what would I pay for
that I never spend time with my dad's
dad I don't know what he thought I don't
know how he was wired I don't know who
he is bro if I had 50 hours of content
or my grandfather on you
I would devour the hell out of it oh my
god but forget about the whole idea of
creating content for becoming an
influencer or become just think about it
one day you're no longer here you got
your great-grandson who wants to know
who his great-grandfather was and he's
binge watches on your episodes yes good
that's my granddad so so that to me is
the pinnacle so if you're gonna do it
for your business if you ain't gonna do
it for anybody create content because
wonder your kids are gonna watch to see
what you were it's the ultimate method
of a journaling yourself
you're able to go back and kind of feel
and see all the stuff that's going on so
that's that part now that's it that part
is that if that doesn't convince you the
other stuff is maybe monetary on the
monetary side you have an edge it's an
online resume if somebody wants to know
who I am nowadays they don't need to go
look at my resume my length and they
just go on youtube and watch a couple
hours of content they say I like this
girl just say I don't like this guy I
don't like you know they're right he is
kind of a you know hard charger he
challenges people litter too much he's
not my kind of a style oh you know what
I like this case my kind of style so
creating content today gives you an
advantage that we never had before
because today the idea of becoming a
celebrity is no longer a big deal today
back in the days the celebrity folks
were the only people that got the rights
managers the right movie producers that
put them in their movies and those guys
were controlled by all over the place I
don't know if you saw the sketch that
the comedian Ricky Gervais stood the
eight minutes if you've never seen it if
you go on Ricky Gervais Twitter account
and you watch that video got like a
hundred million views on Twitter it's an
eight minute skit and he got up there
and he called everybody in Hollywood out
why he says because guess what
nobody needs Hollywood power people
anymore yeah you can go to Netflix now
you can go to Hulu now you can go to so
many different people to get hired today
which means social media became the
great equalizer only if you take
advantage of it yes you have a presence
you have a platform you have a way of
making announcements all you need to do
is same I'm going live here's what I'm
going to talk about the current times
and people can go out there and watch
you and judge you in any way they want
to do and then it's are they gonna work
in your favor
not gonna work in your favor but if you
don't create content today you being
left behind yeah I love that bro and I
actually have thought about that right
like one day my great-grandkids being
able to see this and I've actually
thought about it too the sense where my
mom is actually like someone who I want
my kids and great grandkids to like see
to one day so I interviewed my mom I've
interviewed my grandfather who just
passed away at a hundred years old a
year ago and I and my family was like
what is he doing with a camera I have
videos interviewing my grandfather about
philosophy at a hundred years old and
now I'm like I feel so grateful that I
was able to do that with my grandfather
and I put it out to the YouTube
community for everybody to learn for my
grandfather so um yeah what an
opportunity we really have talking about
our ancestry a couple questions you know
one how would you like people to get
better educated on the contributions and
beauty of the Iranian culture here in
America and how what are those values
that maybe you have gained from your
grandparents your parents coming here
from Iran I mean listen man every day I
wake up I feel like I'm the luckiest man
alive to be in America I mean there's no
question about it I cannot I still
cannot believe on America right now
because this is what we watched in
movies when I landed at John F Kennedy
Airport for the first time after leaving
the refugee camp I was looking for
Sylvester Stallone I said where is rocky
you know where's ha ha ha where's Rocky
you know we just got off the Lufthansa
flight I want to see Rocky
you know I was looking for where is
Pacino where is this guy I want to see
Scarface you know I want to see Patrick
Swayze but yeah we gotta get to the
interview Pacino or De Niro he would be
variant we we were about to do something
with the Hitman and then the executive
producer said no he's connected to real
mob I'm like I'm the last person to be
connected to real mob but they didn't
like the fact that had interviewed real
mobster so lastly they canceled the
interview but that was a whole different
story
but but the point being when I came here
you know you mean to tell me in America
I can have the freedom of speech the
freedom of press to go out there make as
much money as I want to make and have
the kind of life I want to live this is
a great place to be but the partner will
also tell you about Iran and if you
notice is painting behind me there's
painting behind me
is what I look at every day I come in
you see Lincoln yeah Einstein you see
JFK you see Tupac you see myself you see
Sena that's the SHA beer on he's right
in the middle Milton Friedman Martin
Luther King and there's an empty chair
and then here in my office you see Joker
the Hulk and Batman and at the front we
have the Optimus Prime the big nine foot
tall Optimus Prime I have four
communities that have a lot of gratitude
for one is Iran because I was born in
Iran then it's a Syrian community
because my dads are Syria and then it's
our meaning because my mom's are
Armenian and then it's us because I
lived here for the majority of my life
every one of them have shaped a certain
aspect of my life and my character and
they all matter to me a lot so for me to
sit down and say they don't so combining
them to to get us like a good school
your stew your grandma makes to eat that
tastes so good those four different
nations and communities have made me PB
D and I'm grateful for all of them yeah
I love that Patrick thank you and you
know I I learned a lot to like I think
that's what's beautiful about America
right like it really gave us all this
opportunity and my grandparents
immigrated from Italy and my mom from
Colombia so I'm so grateful that I have
those roots in that lineage and now I
have the opportunity like you to change
that you know and and just evolve a
legacy for my family you know and just
create real wealth and prosperity and
knowledge and wisdom that I can pass
down and just change the trajectory of
our of our of our life so I love that so
Patrick I mean I know you have a lot of
leaders that you look up to they're on
your wall but like who are like who are
the few that you really feel are the
ones that you feel are some of the
greatest leaders in history that you
that you really like look at and admire
I mean it's generationally you would
have to put Alexander there for what he
did you have to put Napoleon for his
unorthodox method of getting things done
you you Marcus Aurelius is probably
going to be at the top for me on how he
led Rome here's a guy that's the emperor
of Rome who would have a slave sit right
behind him the entire time wish whisper
to him you're not as important as you
think you are I mean are you kidding me
yeah
what Emperor has a slave telling him
you're not as important as you think you
are that's the only job the slave had at
that time and that's not a normal thing
to do
so marcus aurelius father it's a great
guy if you go watch a video on youtube I
don't know who put it together it's a
great video it's titled Marcus Aurelius
pandemic they went through it and it
talks about how Marcus Aurelius the
emperor of Rome handled the pandemic
cyfle video if you haven't watched it
outside it I would put Shawn on the list
I would definitely put Shawn the list I
put Washington on the list
I'd put Patton on the list I'd put
Lincoln on the list Reagan on the list
JFK on the list MLK on the list yeah put
a lot of those guys on the list yeah I
love that you know one of the things I'm
doing right now Patrick you know cuz I'm
building out I've had leaders create
leaders for the past four years
interviewing some of the greatest
modern-day entrepreneurs and leaders in
history and now I'm actually building
out that community and I'm building out
with what do I you know how do I really
truly want to build a community of
leaders and guide them into becoming the
greatest leader that they can possibly
be then reach their full potential so
what I'm doing is I'm going back in time
one of my things that my grandfather
said to me when he passed away and a
hundred years old was that the
philosophy has already been written you
don't necessarily need to read in any
new books it's go back to what has
already been written by some of the
greats and understand that philosophy
and then bring it into this new world so
that's just something that I'm really
that's that I'm really doing and I'm
sure you probably have really dissected
so many of these leaders but that's
something I'm going through right now
you read meditations have you read the
book meditations no oh oh my gosh put it
on your list okay and Bible you'll
finish that book in 45 minutes
meditations is the only writing they
have till today from Marcus Aurelius the
must read meditate right body here
watching this meditations is for
everybody and crud it's everything he
learned from every experience in his
life what he learned from his grandma
his mom is dad fail your losses kids
parenting love sex leadership money
finance health everything in a 45-minute
agree I love that comment of leader guys
that you look up to and everyone
that you look up to in history right now
so I'm just curious Pat to you I don't
know if you noticed I don't know how
long you may be followed or known about
me but um so I've always grown up very
spiritual but over the past few years
when I was really diving into what my
purpose is because I didn't expect to
sell my company so when I did I was like
what's draw at Adams what's my identity
and it kind of led me to finding truly
my purpose and doing now leaders create
leaders and building that so you know I
started learning about the practice of
meditation in spiritual I do you
practice and what do you do practice
meditation yourself what are some of
that the daily rituals that you do to to
get you fully to have the ability to be
the leader that you are at your you know
in your life for a family man in
business somebody asked if I speak Farsi
mom for see clearly half Museum Adam and
I'm - I'm sorry I'm - I'm you count all
money I'm half Museum anyways - good
question for you I'm uh I'm a big prayer
guy big prayer guy grew up 25 years of
my life of being the biggest atheist you
could meet because living in Iran I
would always be kicked out of Bible
study in Bible school because I'm like
you want me to believe in a God and we
just got bombed on our 67 times I don't
believe in it but I joined the army and
when I joined the army I was invited to
this one camp because I had that third
highest PT score during boot camp and we
went there and I went to this one camp
and I after this camp I'm the you know
we had to stay 30 minutes for a guy to
do Bible study and I was sitting back
and I would play pool and I wouldn't
listen to anything he would say at the
end it was done the guy pulled me aside
he said son can I talk it was a 75 year
old man I said sure he said I got this
book back in 1970 for Christmas it was
given to me by my parents I think you
needed more than I do and he just gave
me the book I said no no I don't need it
I'm good I believe me I grew up in a
strong family I'm an atheist he gave it
to me from that day on till today I pray
three times a day
and here's what my prayers sounds like
God I don't think you exist I think it's
for people who think they need God I
don't need it but if you're out there
great I'll have a conversation with if
you're not I'm talking to myself
on the fool which is good as well
anyways cuz I enjoy talking to myself
and ice
from that approach and then things
started happening to my life so I'm a
big believer of Prayer some call in
meditations I'm a big believer prayer
it's worked for me very well yeah I love
that
no I pray every day and I also meditate
which has been like a really beautiful
practice for me to just reconnect just
to myself and my breath and just allowed
me to build up even more resilience but
I agree man I've been praying my entire
life all right well I mean one last
thing I want to respect your time
Patrick I really appreciate you so much
the work that you're doing in the world
how you show up every day I would love
to invite you want to season six of
leaders great leaders if we can plan it
I'd really love to have you the whole
season of this season is around leaders
that have built movements and that's
something that you have done around your
business and just around value taming so
I would just love to to invite you want
to season six and see if you'd be open
to doing that interview and then just
offer you give any advice about someone
right now I may be out there that is a
young entrepreneur CEO that really wants
to step into being the most powerful
leader that they can be what would be
some advice that you would give to them
right now put a lot of energy and effort
into things you have control over and
nothing into things you do not you know
I spoke to a guy again this morning who
was panicking I called him I said I want
to look at your face he says why my face
I said just just FaceTime me any face
times I said look in my eyes and we're
looking at each other I said you look
scared I'm not scared I said why is your
voice cracking I'm not scared why you
what what are you scared of tell me what
you're scared of and we had a
conversation together for 45 minutes on
what he was scared about I said are you
God he says what do you mean I said why
are you acting like you're God I don't I
don't know what you're saying can you
solve all of the world's problems no why
are you thinking so highly of yourself
to think that you're responsible for
solving every one of world's problems do
you sit on the board where you work with
Anthony Falchi no are you somebody
that's an expert in pandemic viruses or
bio warfare no do you have any influence
with Trump like can you text them and
tell them hey man when are we going to
get the stuff together no are you
sitting
the Democratic National Committee or on
the Republican side or no so why are you
spending so much time thinking about
stuff you have no control the biggest
advice I would give to people during the
time like this turn off all of your news
notification all of them CNN Fox every
single one of them however seven o'clock
in the morning at noon and at seven
o'clock put a reminder in your phone for
you to check the news not the other way
around
your schedule is busy I don't want the
news to send me every single second
something new happens I'm getting a
notification how the hell am I gonna get
anything done I'm not doing that I will
check the news at 7 a.m.
I'll check the news at noon and I'll
check the news at 7 p.m. yeah
I'm else CNN Fox Bloomberg keep it to
yourself I don't need to know about it
right now I got to build my business so
for some people that are so caught up
and all the bad news that's being told
all over the world turn it off put the
energy into things you have control over
I can figure out a way to recreate
yourself because the biggest part today
that's the biggest council I'll get to
wrap up with is the final one you ever
seen a movie count of Montecristo
you ever seen a movie count of monte
cristo no oh my gosh buddy it is all you
it's seriously all you it's pretty much
a form of your story you gotta go watch
count amount of Chris okay well is it
good though here's what happens with the
story so this guy is with a woman who he
loves and she loves him they are crazy
about each other
a man shows up in the picture
manipulates the entire situation because
he wants to take her away from her love
he ends up succeeding he takes his girl
away from him and creates a story and
gets him arrested he goes to jail he's
in jail he's pretty much given up in
life one of his cellmates is a guy
that's read all the books on philosophy
and finance and law during the time
while he's in prison he decides to learn
law as to study economy decides to study
cause he decides to start study
philosophy here's a later he comes out
of prison when he comes out of prison he
implements all of that
becomes the richest man in the community
the name Count of Monte Cristo changes
his name puts the biggest together
invites his ex and her new husband to
his house party he lands in a helicopter
and he's her walking through he comes
close to her and he says how you doing
and she looks at him like what wait a
minute I recognize those those eyes
those eyes are of a mana was crazy about
at one point Wow who is this guy you
seem so familiar and he eventually ends
up getting his girl back and revenge out
that guy what is the moral of the story
sometimes we have to disappear and come
out stronger this is the time to
disappear and when everything settles
down we shock the hell out of the world
because we've recreated ourselves you go
from the 1.0 version up to the 2.0 3.0
4.0 5.0 to the point where no one
recognizes you so it's a great
opportunity today to recreate yourself
and be your own form of Count of Monte
Cristo so powerful boy I can't wait to
watch that thank you for sharing that
that's what I plan on doing I'm just
taking it to a whole nother level I hope
everybody that's watching this right now
you get inspired right now so that you
can come out of this and you know stop
allowing the media to control you I mean
half of it is to political anyways it
not even intellectual like actually
start to do take control of your life
take ownership of your destiny if you if
you go and be intentional right go and
watch value tame it I mean the amount of
wisdom that Patrick is untangled from
some of the greatest minds you know in
in history of these of these generations
like you have the ability to go and
watch those you know I've done an
unbelievable job of also creating all
these interviews like it's all there for
you do that research read the books that
you know Patrick just talked about take
ownership of your life come out of this
even stronger and do it for yourself you
know I think thanks nachos me I love his
line you know the best service success
is the best revenge you know so you owe
it to yourself right now to to kind of
get out take get yourself out of the
noise get yourself out of being
distracted
be single they sit down and get back to
the principles that we talked about
earlier your core values your foundation
of what your vision is you know and the
truth hurts sometimes but get down to
your truth and and know that you know
being you know today you have access to
everything that you can ever need in
order for you to go out there and
succeed you know you know when Patrick
was becoming an entrepreneur even when I
was becoming an entrepreneur I didn't
have the ability to jump on a live
stream like this and learn from a CEO
like this I mean so you have no excuse
but to go out there and do the work and
to implement the sound principles that
are out there that leaders have gone out
and put out there for you to be able to
read and digest so Patrick thank you for
taking time today I look forward to
connecting with you on a deeper level
and continuing to have your your
leadership your mentorship I really
appreciate you both thanks for
everything that you do and who you are
anytime bro thanks for having me man
all right cool later